tonight from minute maid park in houston
texas it is game one of the 2021 world
series between the atlanta braves and
the houston astros heading out to the
mound now to toss our first pitch please
welcome the one and only craig
benchio
on the mount for the astros left-hander
from valdez making his fourth start of
this postseason 1-0 so far a masterpiece
in game five of the alcs in boston and
it'll be jorge solaire leading things
off for the atlanta braves he is the dh
here's one slammed into left field how
about that start to the world series
solaire will take the trip and he puts
atlanta up 1-0
with a first swing of the fall classic
and ball is gone
one-nothing braves
and jorge feels like busting loose
and that's how you start a world series
i think that's a good sign of things to
come that is an amazing start one
nothing atlanta here's freddy freeman
here's freeman with a ground ball what a
play by altuve
he got him what a play
i mean you just can't do it any better
and altuve ended up in center field when
he let that thing go now 3-0 on austin
riley runner at second one down here is
riley with a ball into left center field
it's gonna make it two nothing
cut off by mccormick but it's an rbi
double and the braves have come up
flying here in game one braves have
rolled up their sleeves and they've come
out of the corner just firing haymakers
or the astros here at the top of the
burst if there's a better hired gun in
baseball these days i don't know who it
would be charlie morton is a guy that
you want on the mound yeah he's going
against his former team and a very tough
team is that the bases are loaded for
the astros and kyle tucker
one pitch on the way ground ball right
side aussie gets to it gloves it spins
around fires to first and gets the owl
terrific play by ozzy albees
in shallow right loved it 360 spin and
delivered a good throw
and the astros leave them loaded in the
bottom of the first inning two on one
out solaire who homered on a 2-0 pitch
back in the first inning
grounds one to short correa will throw
to third run scores
and they have peterson hung up tagged
out two nothing now three nothing
atlanta watching from valdez pitch to
eddie rosario
leading it off in the third we did so
much damage against the dodgers and a
ground ball right side base hit that is
already seven hits by the braves against
valdez come out and have a visit with
boudez now and he's not happy at all he
takes a walk around the third base side
of the mound almost wishing he was
anywhere but right there he had a scowl
on his face and now it's just a look of
disbelief
runner at first no one has to do ball
patiently waiting valdez just trying to
fight to stay in the game this one is a
rocket into left and gone five nothing
atlanta
here in the third inning
as duvall goes deep what a start to game
one for the braves
can you think of anything better
than hitting a world series homer not a
thing my gosh that ought to get adam
going
another missile
right into the seats and the fans have
already launched it back here comes
dusty baker that's it for valdez it's
altuve leaving things off top of the
order for houston
now duvet strikes out looking for the
second time
it was
well now charlie seems to be
heard george braves trainers coming out
there to the mound i think that's
suddenly going to be it for charlie oh
no they say it ain't so graves have
announced that charlie morton underwent
x-rays tonight that revealed a right
fibula fracture he's going to miss the
remainder of the world series they say
he's expected to be ready for spring
training in 2022. terrible news for the
braves and for charlie morton and aj
minter is the new pitcher for atlanta
brantley trying to get on in front of
bregman 2-1 pitch he
[Music]
bradley will is into second base with a
one-out double bregman the batter
grounded out his last time up
left side
nice little short hop pickup by third
baseman riley the tag at first two out a
big reason the the braves have five
lefties locked and loaded in their
bullpen is because of this man jordan
alvarez 2-2 to alvarez he struck him out
on a nasty pitch down and away tucker on
third guriel on first trailing by five
and here's mccormick pretty good track
record not only is a big leaguer but as
a minor leaguer against lefties
left side
kicked by swanson
into score is tucker going to third is
guerrielle and it's 5-1 here in the 40.
and the line keeps moving
should have been an easy play for dansby
swanson it certainly should have been
might have been able to turn two on that
it would have been close but obviously
should have gotten at least one see how
the braves want to manage this inning aj
is out there on the mountain brantley
raked one on him his first time up
against him
fly ball into left
back is rosario for the out
and minter will stay in to deal with
bregman the presence of jordan alvarez
on deck pitch
got him looking strike three
that was a beautiful cutter and he
throws bregman there's
oh for one with a walk that'll be the
last batter he faces and he will get an
incredible that a boy when he gets back
to the dugout here's the 2-2
in the air to center field in line with
adam duvall goes over to his right he's
under it and that's a very good inning
for aj minter and a good two and two
thirds all together for aging two on one
out after a double and a walk and ryan
stanek and he's been scoreless in seven
of his eight postseason appearances so
far he's been lights out travis darno
the catcher he's at the plate and the
ground ball to short correa
not in time
stanek wants his dugout to check and
they're going to have the umpiring crew
go look at it this is under review and
it looks like darno's out stanek saw it
and it looks like an inning ending
double play the headphones off he's out
stanic gets his man
dansby back to the top of the order to
soleir first pitch to jorge
check swinging a tapper stanic comes off
the mound he gets to it but has no play
rounding second heading for third dansby
ball kept on rolling by static
that is a check swing base hit for jorge
solaire perfectly placed as they were on
the ship joe and there's nobody behind
standing well he turned into a beach
twail trying to get to that baseball he
was rolling over and trying to corral it
and he was going to try to make a play
to first base but he never got control
of it stanek is out and the left hand of
brooks rayleigh takes over first and
third freddie freeman up for atlanta
and a little pop-up into shallow right
tucker
with swanson tagging
here's the play at the plate and
safe
and swanson gets around the tag
6-1 atlanta here in the eighth
a dash to the plate and i don't think
anyone expected it and it's 6-1 braves
how about that hustle how about that for
an rbi for freddie about a 200-foot fly
ball sacked wide and matsik who came on
to allow a hit and then got a strikeout
of bregman when the seventh deals with
alvarez
and alvarez pokes it deep to center it
sends back duvall still going back at
the wall and it's off the wall alvarez
motoring for second as the ball bounces
back toward the infield and alvarez will
get to third base with his second triple
of this postseason i think that just
shows you how strong he is i'm telling
you he doesn't give way
it's so incredible to be this big and
this strong and not be a free swinger
and he stays on a tough pitch correa the
batter over two with a wall
a run scores albies makes the play and
freeman digs it out and the braves
happily trade and out for a run
now it's julie's turn he's one for three
with a single mr guriel swinging a deep
drive to left field eddie rosario trying
to get there spins around it's over his
head that's off the wall curio heading
for second here comes the throw ozzy
with a tag they got him
wow that ends the inning
huge out at second base
played the carom off the wall spun
around and fired great catch at second
and tagged by ozzy we go to the bottom
of the ninth inning will smith will try
to close it out braves leading six to
two one one how two goes ground ball out
to ozzy boots it picks it up throws to
first base and deep in the heart of
texas the braves have taken game one
they are three wins away from a world
series championship
michelob ultra organic seltzer as real
as it tastes